very different movie this time around
we've been able to kind of get the
introductions are over and you know we
actually assembled some kind of
dysfunctional family but a family
nonetheless and you know of course
before everything goes awry as it has to
but you know I mean it couldn't be any
easier to form a family with this group
I mean we've known each other for years
and it's you know we're very hard to
wrangle I just feel bad for Joss that's
all yes we have Aaron and Lucy which is
very exciting and there's there's such
team players already and they kind of
came in there
wanted to know if we had any advice for
them and I was like um you guys don't
need it you're doing way better than us
we're falling apart you know so yeah a
little bit of fresh blood he's also
James is playing the kind of impossible
role role that when you read that script
you go I'm so glad I don't have to like
try to put this together because it's
all over the place and he just is so
seamless with it I think he you know has
this sort of Shakespearean quality to
him you know he plays it likely or
something like that in it it's really
really effective you know the the film
is only as strong as the villain and I
think James is just a formidable one I
mean of course because I I don't think
I've ever made a movie that kids could
even see before so we have a whole new
fan base which is really exciting and
the fans are awesome they're so
dedicated and so supportive and just
knowing that you have a film coming out
that people are rooting for and you know
that they want to succeed is amazing
you